Happy New Year.
I have a New Year's video prepared,
but before I start that video, I wanted
to jump in with a story and something
that's very important for 2024.
I was at our golf club and the wife
of one of our pros says to me, I
tried learning French on your system.
I understand, but I can't
speak, so I gave up.
I thought that was very, very important.
Most people give up.
The biggest problem language learners
have is they don't stay with it.
Another problem is, some people
convince themselves that they understand
well, but they just can't speak well.
First of all, she probably
doesn't understand that well.
If you have very good comprehension,
like in many different
situations, movies, three or four
people talking to each other.
If you don't understand those situations,
you don't have good comprehension.
So you have to have good comprehension.
But you also can't give up because
language learning actually is not easy.
I sometimes liken it to a jigsaw puzzle.
But imagine a jigsaw puzzle where
you don't know what the picture
looks like and all the little pieces.
Words, phrases that you pick up and
put into the picture, they disappear
on you because you forget them.
And so, there's this
continuing frustration.
The only way you gradually develop a
sense of the language is by continuing.
You're listening and reading and speaking.
And the good news for 2024 is it has
never been easier to acquire the language
through listening and reading because
all the other activities, reviewing
words, which I do, looking at grammar,
which I do, speaking to people, which
I do, it all hinges on having So, yeah,
Content of interest and never has it
been easier to find content of interest
and to bring it in as a video, as an
audio file, as a text file into LingQ or
some other system and use it to learn.
By the way, make sure you take
advantage of LingQ's end of the
year or new year special deals.
Avail yourself of the access
code and get studying.
Now, without further ado, I will
give you The New Year's video
that I produced a little earlier.
So New Year's resolutions, what
do I want to do in 2024 here?
I'll be mostly 78 for
most of the upcoming year.
So insofar as my channel is
concerned, I want to continue
talking about language learning.
I hope to do maybe.
One foreign language, i.
e.
non English video every
month, maybe every six weeks.
I want to continue talking about
language learning, of course, but
I maybe want to expand it into the
subject of learning in general, because
these are things that interest me.
So I want to take my interests and
share them with you here at my channel.
So in talking about the subject of
learning and how the brain learns
more broadly, I will be commenting
on some of the things that.
Other people in, you know, on the
internet through YouTube, influencers,
what they are saying and give you
my sort of reaction to some of the
things that I find on the internet.
Insofar as language is concerned, I want
to continue with my Arabic and Persian
because I'm certainly not satisfied
with where I am in those languages.
In fact, I should promise that I
will do a video both in Persian
and in Arabic in the upcoming year.
Of course, my involvement with these
languages is also a part of my interest
in those histories and those cultures,
because when I learn a language, I
start to sort of get a taste of the
language and of the culture, but
then that drives me to do a lot of
reading, uh, about those people.
So right now, for example, I'm,
I'm listening to an audio book.
On the Arabs, but I also bought the
book and it's by Tim McIntosh Smith.
It's fascinating.
It makes me realize that, you
know, the Arabs, they didn't just
arrive on the scene with Mohammed.
The Arabs as a people from South Arabia
through to the fertile Crescent have
been interacting with each other and with
neighboring peoples for a long, long time.
And it's very useful to
get a sense of all of that.
It puts my Arabic learning.
In a context, and of course the Arabic
learning is not just standard Arabic
where I began, but it's also more
now Levantine Arabic with, I've had,
had some forays into Egyptian Arabic.
And of course this helps because you don't
know if you come across an Arabic speaker,
which form of Arabic they're going to use.
So I will continue my explorations there.
My Persian learning has.
Progress much more quickly than my
Arabic because it's one language.
And I have done a lot of reading, you
know, history of Iran here, a history
of the Tajiks and what else have we got?
The Persianate world.
And these are just some, you
know, lost enlightenment.
You know, which again, talks about
Central Asia, which is largely Persian
speaking, but also Turkish speaking.
And of course I did read a book
on Salim the Magnificent, Turkish.
And of course the Greeks have also been
on the edge of certainly Central Asia have
interacted with Arabic speaking people.
So it's all part of that discovery.
So I will definitely continue
working on those languages.
I may.
Go after Turkish, but if we get Hindi
at LingQ, which I'm hoping we do, then
I want to start exploring India and
learning Hindi, it's not a necessity.
I understand that if you go to India,
a lot of people speak English, but
I just feel that when I get into a
language, it just introduces me to the
culture, the history in a different way.
I get very interested.
I read it more and more on the subject.
So I think I may start in
Hindi this coming year.
We will see.
In any case, I will be dealing with.
Languages that I'm at, uh, call it, uh,
I might be B1 in Persian, A2 in Arabic.
So those are languages that
I'm in the middle of learning.
But if I take Hindi on, then
it'll be a brand new language and
of course, a new writing system.
So, you know, if I think of those
experiences and what advice I might
have for people Who are either
starting from scratch or, you know,
wanting to improve in a language.
My advice usually is you obviously
want to follow your interests.
So if you're interested in, in grammar,
you're going to look into the grammar.
Whenever you are interested, whenever
you're curious, following your curiosity
is always the right thing to do.
But there are moments when you feel
you're not getting anywhere or with a
brand new language, particularly in a
brand new writing system, you wonder
if you are ever going to get there.
If you will ever start to make
sense of this language, and I have
had that feeling so many times.
Particularly most recently with
Arabic and Persian, trying to
learn the script, hearing all these
sounds that are totally new to me.
And yet, while I'm not as good as I
would like to be, I have come a long way.
So I guess what I would suggest to people
as you go into the new year and make your
new year's resolutions, remember that the
heavy lifting is the amount of time that
you have to spend listening and reading.
That's where you will get the biggest
return on your investment of time.
Don't worry about things you forget.
Don't worry about words you forget.
Don't worry about grammar rules
that you forget or that you can't
follow when you're trying to speak.
None of that matters.
One thing matters, staying active,
finding ways to enjoy the process,
finding the process of learning a
language relevant and important to you.
If you can continue to do
that, you will succeed.
So I wish everyone success.
In the new year, in whatever they
choose to do, I didn't talk about
what my personal goals for the
new year are because they are
personal, but they relate to family,
friends, enjoying all the wonderful
things that we enjoy in this life.
So a happy new year to everyone.
Bye for now.